because justices get get appointed for
life people are terrified
of who the justices are yeah well they
kind of should be and they're like
freak like the way that they're gonna
want to impeach trump before he even
appointed anyone
he's not hilarious can you what do you
think would happen if they tried to
impeach him right now for what
i know but if they tried they would
destroy themselves they would totally
destroy themselves
to be fair on this point too because i
brought it up nancy pelosi was asked by
george stephanopoulos
would you consider impeaching trump or
bill barr and then she said well you
know we've got a bunch of options and
then her brain snapped and she went good
morning but what she said
what she should have said is we don't
have any reason to impeach him she could
have just said
why are you asking why would i imp
that's ridiculous that's not what
impeachment's for sir what kind of a
question is that like this
isn't just like a political play thing
that we can do but
she wanted it she wanted to she wanted
that news cycle
so she was like well we have our options
and then trump was like now they're
talking about impeachment
peach they they did did this a second
time
yeah i could see them threatening he's a
little bit more angrier though he's a
little leggy
some people are saying that that's your
pelosi what's do it [ __ ] me
we don't like that very much i don't
like that did you and then
i mean i mentioned it but her brain
broke i saw that clip what was that what
do you think that was
she's just older and under a lot of
stress i think hold on hold on so for
those that aren't familiar
nancy pelosi was talking she was asked
about impeachment
and then george stephanopoulos responded
but you're saying
you won't take impeachment off the table
and she goes good morning
sunday morning that
we have an obligation to the american
people and people were like what
was that that was weird she just like
brain turned off i guess that can happen
every now and again when you have like
again a really high stress job in old
age but it's definitely unsettling
yeah it's really old i mean it happens
at joe biden way more often if we're
being fair
oh for sure should like should we have
like an age limit no
i don't know no because especially with
with genetic therapy the way we can
advance our age we'll be 130
you know do you think so yeah i don't
know if i believe that but i i actually
don't know how it answered the question
i mean at some point
i don't know if i would put a hard age
limit as much as i would say like all
right this person is clearly in a
position where they're no longer able to
govern
and it's funny because for years and
years and years this was a punch line
all the way through my childhood right
and i was born years after ronald reagan
had already died there's this joke oh
isn't it so hilarious that ronald reagan
was going senile at the end of his life
and the republicans had this president
who is who is sort of losing it and
slipping in old age and how incompetent
are they and then the democrats like
went out of their way and chose to
nominate a man whose brain is clearly
not functioning properly when they had
many other options
reagan i've heard that he had some
information
and they wanted to testify and get it
out of him and he didn't want to give up
the information so he
act he said that he was going senile and
couldn't remember
i wouldn't know anything but then he
went really well yeah exactly
didn't he think i don't know did you
think that movie war game was like a
real thing
what yeah you know that movie where the
kid like what was that
you know the movie where the kids
playing the the computer game and after
broderick
yeah was that it and the computer's
gonna fire nuclear missiles or something
and he thought it was real and he was
like oh no
well yeah i don't know about any of that
something like that i just know that
that was the bit that they always did
everyone always thought it was hilarious
that reagan was slipping and it was just
indicative of this
grave incompetence on the right side of
the political aisle and then
they had the choice in pictures if
you're if you're saying that you think
we're going to live to be like 130 then
what about these lifetime appointments
for supreme court
we got to change it it's got to change
they used to live not that long
no they live i mean i mean 70 maybe
that's life expectancy has been
like relative like only gone up a little
bit desperately have to change the life
appointments it should be 40.
i don't know i mean i think that's i'm
really skeptical of the idea that we'll
be able to extend the human life
uh expectancy that long and if we do i
think that's a bridge we would
really need to cross once we got there
for now i would just say maybe there's
something to be said about a person
being too incompetent to do the job
anymore and you have that discussion i
don't know that i would set a heart age
limit for it
yeah what about sure cause like look at
thomas so i mean we haven't heard from
thomas so much lately but
he's he's certainly getting older and
he's just as sharp and brilliant as he's
ever been
what do you think about term limits for
justices for justices that's a tough one
i don't know i really don't know i
haven't thought it through enough
i've actually never really given that
specific question any thought so it
wouldn't probably wouldn't be
responsible for me to answer
all a lot of like what this conversation
specifically is predicated upon whether
or not life expectancy will be
exponential mm-hmm but there's uh
are you guys familiar with aubrey de
gray yeah you might be is he stuck out
the really long beard yes
yes i've heard a few uh talks from him i
i saw him speak once and he said
that we he said what did he say that
like
people under the age of 45 and this was
i think this was
10 years ago will live to be a thousand
and he said
i don't either but his point was yeah
it's ridiculous
his point was this he said it's not that
we're going to one day
invent this pill that you just take and
also you know you live to be a thousand
it's that you're going to turn 50 and
they're going to cure this
you're going to turn 55 they're going to
cure this and then medical technology is
going to start advancing faster than
people are dying
so you'll always be sick you'll always
be weak you'll always be dying but
they'll constantly be treating and
curing and rejuvenating
and then so it's kind of like this
period where we're dipping and then
we pull back up and medical technology
keeps us alive
yeah i don't know if we if we have
lifetime appointments under the
assumption that
you know these people will die at some
point we still have the problem of
people who become completely
incapacitated yes serving on the supreme
court
maybe cognitive tests or something yeah
exactly exactly um
it's interesting what you're saying
about life expectancy and you sort of
alluded to this earlier when you said
life expectancy has not significantly
grown
um people will say like oh in the past
life expectancy was only 30 but
obviously that's because there's so much
infant mortality changing the average
it wasn't out of the ordinary or totally
unheard of for a person to live to 80 or
90 or even 100 but it is out of the
ordinary for a person now to live to
like 130 140
in fact i don't think anyone's ever
lived that long so that's why i'm
skeptical that our medical technology
will ever get us to the point where
that's possible have you heard of
nicotinamide mononucleotide
no sure mmn you can get it you can buy
it and you take it with uh resveratrol
which is the
uh active chemical in like red wine and
like purple vegetables you know eggplant
um it causes the tilap telomeres
telomerase telomeres
just to regrow so your proteins you have
these proteins called sirtuins in your
body
and there's five of them one of them
measures the energy in your mitochondria
so when a cell splits if it doesn't have
enough energy one of the new cells
doesn't have enough energy so it clips
off the end caps of its telomeres
to compensate but if the measurement
process is accurate because the sirtuins
are good
then when the cell splits both stay
alive and the telomeres stay
healthy and long as you get older this
sirtuin
cert two starts to degrade but with nmn
nicotinamide mononucleotide and other
chemicals
they keep pumping this to your body
keeps making the sirtuins
so you basically don't get older is the
idea so what you're saying is
we should all get blood transfusions
from young people who do nothing but
eat healthy and work out at the gym oh
my god doesn't peter thiel do that yeah
yeah what is that stuff called is that
word banned on youtube yeah i have no
clue gonna give this demonstration
someone believes that yeah maybe i think
people do do that really they do
i i i could be wrong but i read that
peter thiel did it maybe that's not true
and maybe it's a smear of him that
wouldn't you know so people used to
affect human hearts you know
for their courage right yeah exactly
well that that does work
you gain their courage i think so is
that is that what you've been is that
why you're so comfortable
exactly that's why i just speak my mind
that's why i make internet car changes
very courageous
so let's talk about uh you know the
supreme court man yeah supreme court
uh mitt romney i guess is kind of
pulling back a little bit
he said he's not gonna promise trump
he's gonna give him the vote he needs
even though he said he was gonna vote to
confirm whoever but uh
you think uh i guess everyone's saying
it's gonna be amy coney barrett
and the concern is that she is a devout
catholic
and so the left is concerned for whom
sir
well the the left is concerned for
themselves yeah
because you know well and we talked
about this a little bit earlier but
she's also a constitutional originalist
so they're saying she's going to like
implement this this radically
catholic interpretation of the
constitution when she herself has said
she actually just wants to look back to
what the founding fathers initially
intended because that is the job of
supreme court justice that's what you're
supposed to do
we we were talking with um i think it
was colin wright and i hope i'm not
putting words in his mouth because maybe
i'm misremembering
but he said something like he would
prefer kids learned creationism over the
social justice stuff
and so i'm like well now you got a
liberal who's going to be in favor of
yeah a devout catholic supreme court
justice
uh because the potential that you get a
hard-left identitarian
cultist oh yeah but you don't record the
worst of two things
i don't know i disagree that she's the
worst also i mean people are calling her
like a catholic extremist but she's
she's just a practicing catholic it's
funny people
part of the reason that you know joe
biden is not a practicing catholic is
because the media has never called him a
religious extremist which is what they
always do when you follow the most basic
tenets of the catholic faith
i mean she's pro-life and she doesn't
want catholic companies to be forced to
pay for a board of patients which i
think
or birth control which i think is like
pretty straightforward that's not an
extremist belief in fact i know
many non-religious people uh who believe
that
and uh she has seven children god forbid
how dare she so she's crazy and
different and weird
did you see the tweet where they said it
was uh what do they call it terrorism
there was a there was a viral tweet like
a woman with like her she had nine kids
and then
her belly was like number ten and it
said like this is terrorism or something
like that wow
yeah i think it's just aggressive i
think it's just confrontational now
um what was it that they said about
antifa they're just a little
confrontational
yeah no i think that's like why is why
is procreate why would procreating be
terrorism like who's forcing her to have
these children she's just having these
children dude you could have one kid and
be a horrible parent and have 20 kids
and be a member fantastic parent yeah
exactly
exactly i mean historically it was
normal to have many more children like
the idea that that's terrorism is so
stupid
i don't even know where to begin with it
well they're just saying it because you
have
like the social justice narrative yeah
you know
children bad yeah kid's bad it's bad for
it's bad for the climate
you know you can't have kids over
population yeah
on the earth not the number of us of
course yeah exactly i don't even say
it's not even so much like
the way that we're formed because as we
were talking about this a little bit
earlier but
there are certain resources that um
we've been
depleting i suppose like fossil fuels
but as the population has increased
global poverty has decreased it's not as
if there's been this
fierce competition for resources with
each new mouth because every single
person
is is also an asset i mean people create
things and they tend to create more than
they themselves
will need and so it passes on to
everybody else but
so we're talking about this too i i
think we will eventually have an
overpopulation problem in simple math
if at a certain point we can't have more
people because there's a finite amount
of space
you know and we need a certain amount of
space for farming we were i've been
looking at like uh
how to grow certain like crops and like
in a garden i'm not talking about
starting a farm or anything like that
and they talk about like the certain
amount of acreage you need and stuff so
clearly there's a mathematical formula
for how many people can exist with how
much farmland you have
at some some point we'll hit that number
yeah i think i think if that's possible
then it's something that would sort of
work itself out and it would hit an
equilibrium and i'm sure you would agree
that like population control is nowhere
near being the answer to this kind of a
question
but equilibrium
yeah i don't know yeah it usually means
people starving but i i don't know
that's human i don't know that
humanity's ever going to get there
well that we are going to i don't
believe we are we'll send people to mars
but think we can build
cities in the sky so check this out do
you think so yeah this is a long-term
idea but
the way boats work in the ocean you have
a hollow
tube basically a hollow circle that
floats in the water because it's lighter
than the water so if you had a hollow
circle in the air that's lighter than
the air basically a vacuum like a like a
hot air balloon and we could name it
something after a guy maybe like um
hindenburg
the hydrogen is is lighter than the air
around it gigantic
huge mass of of structures if you've
been watching a lot lighter than air
um no i've never seen it that's actually
you should watch it because it's a
beautiful film you fill the
chamber with lots of little circles with
like hydro gel you can pump it with
lighter than air materials
and i think we can get giant land masses
to float and then we can plant crops
i don't think we can do it that way yeah
apparently uh in venus we could
they're like floating there's like
really dense gases and you could like
make a floating city so there's been
like sci-fi that have talked about it
yeah but people don't talk about the
problem with mars is that there's no
uh magnetosphere right right one but how
do we do that do we like bring a bunch
of magazines have you seen the core
that movie were they like yes then they
nuked the core of the is that we're
gonna do
why would you do this have you seen if
you see that big gash on mars it's like
hundreds of thousands of miles long
it looks like some planetoid hit mars
and scraped across
it and ripped it open so all the iron
spewed out of it in the
magma that's why it settled his iron
oxide dust all over the surface
interesting so like it's core got gutted
or it's it's magma got gutted yeah i
have no idea
but they probably should still have a
accor i just don't it's it's not quite
as
i don't know i don't know anything about
mars elon thinks i should read the
polls to get it to get away elon said
what that we should nuke the polls of
mars interesting how many nukes would
you need for this yeah exactly
like all of them would have asked them
what if what if a couple of them just
miss
mars and they're just going through that
because it's actually hard to get things
right at the exact
window where they're going to hit
something that far away so you just have
a couple nukes go past and then we start
an intergalactic war
hundreds of thousands of years later
millions maybe it just hits some plan
and it's still active and we plant the
bomb
you have to plant something oh yeah so
like i'm imagining it's like really
funny
like this like watching this like this
nuke just like it
narrowly misses and then i can imagine a
song like spanish flea playing is it
like
for 100 million years is just drifting
aimlessly and then finally reaches this
ridiculously intelligent advanced
species with interstellar travel
but they've they've lost the ability to
enter like to stop this because
oh my god it's like what do we do it's
like i don't know we haven't dealt with
nukes in like
5 000 years and then it like blows up
one of their colonies so they're like
war
and they come to earth and it's like
it's a decaying blob of nothing and like
it's been hundreds of millions of years
there's nothing left humans are gone
it's wiped out oh i sure hope not
but maybe we're on mars because we knew
it was successful i got up to the polls
and i just figured it out what is it
what actually happens is if it's just
traveling
physically through space yeah and
eventually we discover interstellar
travel like wormholes and stuff
it hits us yeah i was gonna say what if
the universe is just repeating like
pac-man you get to one end and then it
comes back the other way and then it is
the snook just comes back and hits us
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time